thank you anna so to help us understand
exactly what's happening in ukraine i'm
joined now by our defense and security
analyst michael clark good afternoon to
you michael um first off looking at this
map here um has russia made any advances
really since last week on the map but as
the ministry of defense said this
morning
russia seems to be now going in for a
strategy of attrition which means
they're bringing more troops in from
lots of different areas to bring more
artillery in so they're going to grind
it out which means more bombardments and
sadly probably a lot more civilian
deaths in kiev in particular
they're trying to bring their artillery
uh into range of the city they haven't
surrounded the city as quickly as we
thought but when they get their
howitzers within 15 mile range then they
can threaten to bombard the city almost
at will with old-fashioned artillery
shells okay now really important to
russia in the south if we look at the
map um there
a mikolai
and also mario pole tell me what's
happening there and why also they're so
important yeah mikolayev is the gateway
to odessa which is the main strategic uh
objective uh in that part of the of the
country and
nikolai the russians are unable to
actually secure the city they've they've
been repulsed several times the
ukrainians are counter-attacking quite
effectively and they've even pushed them
back and as you've indicated they're on
the icon they seem
for a while at least to have got him
behind them if they have that will be
extremely interesting so mikolaiv is is
a really tough nut for the russians to
crack and they seem to be doing worse
rather than better over the last two or
three days and mario paul has been
bombarded hasn't it for weeks now
tell me what the latest is there 80 of
the housing stock is gone either
destroyed or uh or damaged and the siege
of mario paul goes on they're still
fighting in the city center which means
that this the the city hasn't completely
fallen but it looks as if it's probably
close to falling and of course lots of
people still in that theater there who
need to be saved indeed um looking again
at the wide map of the whole of ukraine
um
russia haven't made the progress that
they want how likely is it do you think
there'll be some kind of pince emotion
well logically they have to do a couple
of things they have to try and unite
their southern and their northern forces
they've got to drive down to the south
or up from the north somewhere around
poltava one would guess the ancient city
of baltimore they will try to meet up
and they will try to encircle the
ukrainian forces who are fighting so
hard in the east of the country
particularly down here in the southeast
the ukrainians have therefore got to
decide at some point whether to uh
withdraw westwards to live to fight
another day and probably to be available
for the defense of kiev but if they do
that then they've got to give up a lot
of the defense of these these areas that
they've been so ferocious about for the
first three weeks that's a difficult
problem for them on the other hand the
russians are making pretty hard work of
this sort of link up but logically
that's what they've got to try to do
okay and briefly and we've heard a lot
haven't we about this hypersonic missile
in the west that's been deployed tell me
about that yeah the kinzel missile
dagger in english there it is on a
mig-31 it can be delivered just by an
interceptor aircraft no defense against
it it's a new threshold these weapons
were developed for the apocalyptic idea
of war between the superpowers not war
between us a smaller country in eastern
europe so it's it's another threshold
crossed i'm afraid okay so finally
looking back at that whole map of
ukraine
not a lot changing but actually very
much a case of watch this space
absolutely